ありがとうございます今日あのみなさんこんにちは
これあの初めて僕ここに立ってみたんですけど全く皆さんの顔が見えないんですね
あのーちょっと驚いてますか今日あの私は何者かというとあの大学生の方がですね企業
学ぶビジネススクールを運営しているミル付の黒い子と申しますよろしくお願い致し
ます
で私はですねあのずっと就職支援の仕事に携わっていましてでその後今企業支援の
ちょうどに携わっていてで合計10年ぐらいずっとキャリア領域で仕事をしてまいり
ました
そういったバックグラウンドをもとにですね今日お話しさせて頂きたい内容としては
こちらキャリアに保険をかけようと理由そんなお話をさせて頂ければと思っています
で何を言っているかと申しますとですね今あの私たちのキャリヤ
仕事人生ですけれどもそういった仕事人生は今想像以上のリスクにさらされております
何を言っているかといいますと
あるオックスフォード大学の先生の研究によりますとですね
あの it 化の進展によって10年後我々が今取り組んでいる仕事の70%の仕事は
消えてなくなるというふうに言われています
この今こういった事態を受けてですね我々の若い方の中に
中にはプログラミングを学ぼうと it から進展して今行われているような仕事が
なくなるのであれば
プログラミングを学んでおけばいいんじゃないかというところでいろんな it スキル
を学んでいらっしゃる方も増え続けていらっしゃいます
でただ今から10年後20年後についてはこのプログラミング技術デスラー
ロボ
とか勝手に開発をし始めるようになるとも言われていてどんなスキルを持っていても
10年後には多くの仕事がなくなるというふうに言われています
そんな中でもしわれわれが取り組んでいた仕事がなくなったらどうなるかというとご
存知の通りですけど
リストラされて我々は失業していくそういった結果になっていきます
もし我々が25歳くらいの若いタイミングでリストラされたとしてもまた次の仕事は
当然ながらあります
若い方であれば今までの経験がなくても再就職をしていくことができまして転職先は
いくらでもあります
ただ我々が今25歳だと仮にした時に15年後
40歳になったときにそれまで15年間
出席してきた仕事が一切必要とされなくなって社会から必要とされなくなって亡くなっ
てしまった場合
40歳で新しい仕事に取り組もうと思った時に転職先あるかと言われると
残念ながらありません
40歳ぐらいになってくると新しい仕事に転職をしようと思ってもそれまでのキャリア
経験が求められてしまって転職しようと思ってもなかなかできない
そういった状態になります
そんなことを想定して私たちの中で10年後今われわれが取り組んで仕事もしくは
学生さんがあればこれから新卒で就職していくであろう仕事会社が効いてなくなって
しまったとしても私は準備万端だから大丈夫だよと言えるような方ってどれ位
いらっしゃいますしてを上げていただきますですあの
見えない
んですが
またもほぼいらっしゃらないんじゃないかなと思うんですけど
そうあの多くの方がこういったことを想定してアクションできているかというと
なかなかできていないんじゃないかと思ってまして
ただこういった形で40歳になった時にリストラされたとしても最低限自分の生活時
ぐらいであれば自分で稼ぐ事が出来ていれば最低限の生活を行ってことができました
さらに
ただ生活できるだけだと全然人生が面白くないそうなった
しても自分がやりたい好きなことを仕事にできる仕事にできるというのは自分で事業と
して作ってことができる力があれば
自分がやりたいことを人生をかけてずっと生活もしながらちゃんと追求していくことが
できるということになります
そういった自分で仕事を創り出すような着方を目指していくためにこのラーメン大企業
という保険をかけませんかという事は今日
をさせて頂きたいと思っていますラーメン大企業というのは何を言っているかといい
ますと
我々が
起業しようとしたときにいきなり俺はソフトバンクを超えるぜと米楽天を超えるぜ
みたいなことを言ったとしてもですねなかなか
じゃあ何から始めたらいいのかというところがイメージがつかない方が多いんじゃない
かというふうに思ってまして
ただラーメン大企業というのに入っているかと言うとさっきの一風堂さんが
いらっしゃいましたけど
一風堂で働こうぜみたいな言葉が入ってるわけじゃなくてですねあの一風堂さんで毎日
ラーメン
を食べ食べ続けることができるような最低限の生活史を稼げるぐらい
次に10万とか値50万でもいいんでですねそれぐらいの生活史を稼げるぐらいの企業
からまずスタートしてみるということをやってみたいからでしょうか中ご提案お供させ
て頂ければと思っています
僕がこんなことを考え始めたきっかけはですね全てこちらのリーマンショックが限定に
やりました
で当時2008年リーマンショックが起こったときに僕は何なっていたかと言いますと
名古屋愛知県名古屋してですね自動車部品メーカーさんを中心にして
就職支援サービスを提供しておりました
当時あの自動車産業というのがですね日本日本の自動車産業は世界でナンバー1ど
活躍を続けておりましたのででこういったですね工場の製造現場で叩かれるような方々
の採用を愛知県だけだと採用が一切できないものですから日本全国で採用活動を行って
いました
そういった活動の就職支援が仕事をしていて我々は
は世界ナンバーワンの会社の就職を成長支援しているんだという事情を持って仕事をし
ていましたし
ここで働かれている方々も世界ナンバー1の仕事を我々しているんだという自負を持っ
て仕事をしていましたただリーマンショックが起こった瞬間から何が起こったかという
と
工場は一斉に低床いたしました
ってそれ故何が起こったかというと当然ながら工場が止まっている以上
人を雇い続けることができないもんですからリストラが行われ
で当時この製造工場の製造現場で働かせるという方はどんな形で生活していたかという
と会社が用意して寮に住んで
で住み込みで働いていらっしゃいました了出ると
でしかし当然ながらリストラをされるとまずは寮から追い出されます
彼らがそれ以降をどうやって生活していこうとするかというとまずは地元に帰ろうと
思われる方もいらっしゃるんですけれども
一方で地元に帰っても仕事がないからわざわざ後に出てきているので地元に帰っても
仕事がないと思って中で転職活動をしようとがんばりますただ家から追い出されたん
ですねじゃあまずはすぐところ探さなければならない
そう思って彼らがどうやって生活
の住処を探したかというとまずはマンションを借りようと思いますただ給料がない給料
がないとマンション借りることはできないんです
じゃあどうするかというと彼らはホテルに住み込んででホテルに泊まりながらですね
ハローワークに通って転職活動を続けていらっしゃいましたただ当然のように多くの方
はそれほどの貯金があるわけでもございませんのでいつのまにか貯金が尽きて
路上に出てくるとで路上人数で敵ながら
戦勝活動を続けているということが起こっていました我々と20代30代の若い方々が
路上に出てきてホームページになっているということが発生していました
それまで約1年くらい前までであれば大歓迎されていた仕事であったとしても日本全国
で9人が行われてぜひここで働いてくれと誰もが言っていた仕事であるにも関らず
ある瞬間を境に一斉に必要とされなくなっちまう
そういったことが発生します
で多くの方々がその仕事に就くためにいろんな技能を磨き続けて学校に通って勉強して
まいりましたにも張らずある瞬間から
一切必要ないということを言われてしまうそんなことが発生していきましたん
その時に私が感じたのはある
キャリアにはリスクがあるんだということでした
仮にいろんな勉強してきて学校卒業して世界ナンバーワンの会社に就職をしたとしても
それでもこういった時代が発生してくるんだということを痛切に感じました
俺が一番最初の原点の経験でした翌年
私はさらに大きい経験を致しましたそれは何かというと親友のリストラでした
これは何を言ってるかと申しますと私は社会人なってから入社1年目の時にある
グループ会社に出向してましたのであるグループ会社の中にすごい多くの友達がいたん
ですけれどもその中に
まさにこの子さ
大学を卒業したですね同期がいましてでその人とかなり仲良くなっていました
ん
で私はたまたまその時にですねちょうどいいタイミングで結婚アッシュ
結婚したものですからその友達にぜひ結婚式に来てくれよということを声をかけて
もらっていたんですけれども
その時に言われた言葉がこれでした
かなりプレッシャーかけられた辞めさされて今仕事を探して転生活動してるんだけど
全然千葉ないんだ
大変申し訳ないけど結婚集ところじゃないんだということを
親友から言われました
そのあるグループ会社は私が入社した当時で行くと同期が六十数人いたにも関わらず
このタイミングで言いますと
たった1ケタしか人数がいなくなっていますほとんどの人々がリストラにあっていまし
た全く同じ動機の人々がです
その時に通過しました私は名古屋で働いていた時に分かる方がホームになっている
ところを見た瞬間だけで言うと
また社会問題としてこういうことが起きているんだという風にしか捉えていなかったん
ですけれども
あくまでこのキャリアにはリスクがあるということが早稲田大学を出て代表に就職者と
しても自分の身にも降りかかってくるんだということにこのときに初めて痛感したん
です
同時に私自身が働いていた本社においてもいろんな説明会が開かれ始めました
企業年金制度が変更になります
退職金制度が変更になりますそういった説明会が開かれてきました
私はこのときに初めて自分がもしこの会社で65歳まで働いたとするとどれだけの
インカの収入が得ることができるんだろうという事を本当に初めて計算しています
すると分かったこととしては仮に65歳まで僕はこの会社で働いたとしても
老後全く生活していくことができないじゃないかということに改めて気づいたんです
このときに初めて本当に自分ごとにお帰ります自分のキャリアにはリスクがあるんだと
いうことに気づきました
ただここまできたとしても僕には密かな地震がありました
それはなぜかというと当時働いていた企業の中では営業成績で一番であって
でこれは壇上で表彰されている写真ですけれどもかなり活躍しているというふうに勝手
に思っていたんでした俺優秀じゃないかというふうに勘違いしてまして
でどんな仕事もできるんじゃないかという風に思い込んでました当時は営業成績が良い
ということに加えてさらに当たる
主軸の新規事業を宣伝企画スタッフとかやらせていただいていたものですから
僕は仕事ができるんじゃないかと仮に僕はリストラされたとしても自分に新しい事業を
作り出すことができてその仕事によっていくらでも大きいほどやってることができるん
じゃないかとそう信じていました
ただ
こういった社会情勢や友達のリストラというところを受けて何か室末の不安を覚えて
ちょっと土日で事業立ち上げてみようと思って立ち上げを初めて観ました
そこでどんなどんな授業を立ち上げてみたかというとですね
こんな事業立ち上げました
中学1年生を対象にした自立型中学生養成講座とよくわかんない鉱山多くてですね
こんな折込チラシたんですけどもこれ折込チラシをですね世田谷区一面にですね折込
チラシを入れて自分のポケットマネーから50万くらい鉱工業払って投下してみたん
ですこれあの見ていただけばわかると思うんですけど何やるかよくわかんないんですね
これでお客さんが集まるわけじゃないよん
いうことであのー結果を始まりました
今まで自分はすごい圧倒的に勇者なんじゃないかと勘違いしたんですけども
どうすればこの事業がうまくいくのかというところがまったくわかりませんです
ん
改めて振り返ってみると自分で新しく事業を立ち上げようとしてみて気づいたことが
あります
それは何かというと
この事業を成功させていくために勇者の仲間を集めようと思った時もどうすればいいん
だ
いうことが全くわかりませんでしたさらに事業を立ち上げていくために本当に作れば
いいか
ホームページどうやって作ればいいんだろうとで誰が発注すればいいんだろうという
ことを考えたとしても入れ方がまったくわかりませんです
しかも名刺の作り方も分からない
であのセミナーを開こうとしても場所の狩り方とどこどこどこで場所を変えることが
できれば一番効率的なんだろう
いうことを考えたんですけども最適な方法というのがよくわかりませんでした
その時に改めて気づいたんです
大企業で新しい事業を立ち上げて専念企画スタッフをやっていたとしても自分でゼロ
から事業を作っていくっていうことも力とは全然違うんだということに気づきました
なぜかというと温めてくれ帰ってみると第1期の中で新しい事業を経営していたとして
も優秀な人材をいかに調達してくるかというところについては圧倒的に優秀な jins
目のスタッフが集めてきてくださって言ってで最適な場所を調達しようと思った時でも
優秀が遭遇のスタッフが考え抜いて場所を調査してきてくれていました
民主の発注しようと web サービスを作ろうと思った時もアシスタントの方が勝手
に動いて素晴らしいサービスをあの素晴らしい民主を調査してきてくれています
大企業で働いている間は知らぬ間に優秀な人々が陰で支えてくれていたからこそ初めて
授業が成り立っているんだということに気付いたんです
あくまで自分がやっていた仕事というのは大きい需要のなかの一つの授業の中のたった
1一つの役割
戦略を作るという役割にフォーカスしてそれしかできていなかったんだということ日本
時に初めて気づいた
ません
与えられた仕事をやっているだけではまずい
いうことを感じました
大きいシグ大きい会社の中で事業運営に携わるということではなくて
小さな事業でもいいからこそゼロから自分で事業を立ち上げているとそういった経験
そういった力を身につけていかないと自分は退職した後にせいかしてことすらできない
んじゃないかということに気づいてそこからこのラーメン大企業というところ
考え始めて動き始めましたって
堀っていう欄で企業というところは先ほど申し上げたとおり最低限の自分の生活ぐらい
は稼げる仕事と言っておりますので
だいたい月に10万から50万とか100万ぐらいの収益は稼げるような授業をまずは
立ち上げてみようと思って立ち上げてみたんです
って具体的に言うと札響出てきたの教育サービスとかイベント授業ウェブメディア
株式投資や fx 不動産投資等を含めておりますけれどもいる
同じ行を
挑戦いたしましてで土日はとにかく事業に挑戦し続けました
結果としてあるあの3年後
税職を辞めるタイミングまで言いますと大体月100万円くらいの収入を得ることが
できて
でそういった収入があるからこそ自分がやりたい事業に対して本気でコミットして進め
ていくことができるところまでになりました
私がやりたかったのは僕のミッションとしてはこの女が未来に希望を持てる社会を作る
ということにコミットしていてねそのために企業化率の向上一人でも多くの方が企業に
踏み出してるの社会をつくるんだとそういったことに
ミッションビジョンを掲げておりますのでそういったことを突き詰めてやっていきたい
と思っていますだからこそ今やっているような大学生の方が企業に踏み出せるような
ビジネスクールを
今運営しているんですけれどもそういったも立ち上げを全力で行っています
このときに大事なのはもし僕がこの仮に一月100万くらいの収入を得ることができて
いなかったらどうなったかというとこのビジネスクールを通じて短期的に収益化を図ら
なければならないということを突き詰めて考えてですね
ものすごく短期的な視点に立ってビジネスを考えていたと思うんです
ただそうなると何が起こるかというと教育サービスというのは時間がかかる
サービスですので短期的な成功を求めた瞬間にお客様を離れていくんです
なので絶対今みたいにうまくいっていなかったと思いますただ私は月々100万くらい
のちょっとした生活者は稼ぐことができていたからこそ
純粋にお客様のことを浮きあっ
a サービスを設計していくことができましたそのためにその後参加させていただいた
ある会社さんが主宰する企業コンテストでは優勝することができて
でその後もいろんな先輩京香さんとか投資家さんからご愁傷痛いことができて
で今週で言いますとこの渋谷移動している企業先生という本も出版させていたことが
できて次の成長の兆しが見えてくるところまで
てくることをまいりました
なぜここまでこれだかというところを改めて振り返ってみると
最初から申し上げている通り
ちょっとしたビジネスを愚直に立ち上げて言って小さい授業なんだけれどもそれを
積み重ねて最低限の生活費を稼ぐ力があったからという所が一つと後は大企業で一部の
仕事だけに倒せるんじゃなくてゼロから事業を作り上げていくという経験をいくつも
いくつも積み重ねてきていたからこそ今の授業が立ち上がったんじゃないかなという
ふうに思っています
ああああああ
今我々の社会については社会的な変動が大きく体
最初に申し上げた通り10年後には70%仕事がなくなると言われていますこういった
激しい返答が石今だからこそ我々もただ就職するとでただ大企業に就職していくという
だけではなくてちゃんと距離キャリアに保険をかけていこうということを
兵庫店
させて頂きたいと思っていてただ具体的なアクションとしてはまずはラーメン大企業
費50万円とか100万円でもいいのでまずは小さくてもいいから自分で事業を
立ち上げるという経験をぜひ積み始めていただきたいというメッセージでございました
以上でございありがとうございました
がとうございましたーーー